-Welcome to the show!
I've been looking forward
to this for a very long time.
-Oh,
well, thanks for having me.
It's a treat!
-So you win a Pulitzer
for "All the Light
We Cannot See,"
which is a book
that I loved a great deal.
It was nice to find out that
other people loved it as well.
So I'm worried, though --
Not worried,
but I guess I'm curious --
when you're writing
a follow-up book,
how much is that
in the back of your head,
that the last one
won the Pulitzer?
-Oh.
When you're writing,
it's not as much in your head,
but it's in your head
at other moments.
Like you're on the airplane
and you can't finish the easy
level Sudoku and you're like,
"Pulitzer Prize Winner Fails
Again at the Easy Sudoku."
[ Laughter ]
You know, there's moments
the imposter syndrome comes out.
-Sure.
-Thankfully, writing is
so engaging to me that,
five minutes into your workday,
you're just trying to solve
the problems
of what you're writing
and that whole world
kind of strips away.
But there's moments you're doing
the dishes or something
and you're like, "Oh, wait.
Am I supposed to do this again?"
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, I kind of feel like.
-You're talking about like
sort of solving
the problems of writing
and I think that there's always,
any writer, no matter
what they're writing,
that's part of it.
In "All the Light
We Cannot See,"
there were two perspectives.
This book, it seems like
you made it more complicated
for yourself --
five perspectives,
three different eras.
As I'm reading it,
I'm sort of picturing
how you had to map it out.
Did you physically map it out?
-I did.
Like a serial killer,
that kind of mapping.
[ Laughter ]
It's crazy.
So, "All the Light" was kind of
an A/B, back-and-forth structure
between two characters,
Werner and Marie, A/B.
Occasionally, I'd break that --
A/B, A/B --
ping-ponging back and forth.
But that was just enough
for me to push my brain
to hold that in.
And then, for this book,
which took me seven years,
I decided to go for five,
so like A/B/C/D/E.
And I'm trying to keep
all five plates spinning
in a reader's mind
and you get anxious
that you'll forget what's
going on with character D,
so you have
to go touch that plate
every once in a while,
to keep it spinning.
So, often, at the beginning,
you don't really know
your structure perfectly,
so you're just drawing
these really rudimentary maps,
but, once you're years
into the project,
I'm drawing pretty
sophisticated maps,
trying to have like
all these little braids working
through the structure of it.
Visual representation
helps me kind of figure out
where the story's going
sometimes.
-And, because of that,
does that mean
you can't just write
character A from start to finish
and then move on
to the next one?
Do you have to then
sort of just, as a writer,
be going back and forth
between all of them?
-Yeah, yeah.
I will rarely write something
in the order in which
a reader will read it.
You're often
disrupting chronology
just because you need to know
where you're going.
It's just like when you leave
for somewhere,
you should know
your destination.
So, even though it's never
really a straight line,
often, I'm writing the ending
long before I've built
all the connective tissue to it.
The great joy
of an ensemble novel like this
is there's always something
you work on.
When you get stuck
on this character,
you can go work
on a character --
I've got characters
in the 15th century.
I'll go work on the 15th century
for a week.
And then,
if the paint starts to dry
on the contemporary stuff,
I'm like,
"Oh, you know what? This week,
I gotta go work on those guys."
So it's kind of really joyful.
There's always something
you can be working on
and, anytime you get stuck
in a place,
you just find a new route.
You can kind of figure out new
stuff to be happy working on.
-That is wonderful
and there is --
there are many joyful elements
to this book,
but it also sort of deals
with this, you know,
the idea
of a catastrophic future,
which it feels like so many
of us are drawn to,
when we choose our fiction,
not just in,
you know, literature,
but in television and films.
Was that something
that you wanted to focus on,
or did you just find that it was
the idea in your head
that you wanted
to put on the page?
-Yeah, great question.
Well, have you heard the phrase
Cloud Cuckoo Land before?
-I had never heard
Cloud Cuckoo Land.
-I think a lot of folks have
and it's more present, I think,
in British and Irish English,
but the phrase
way predates English.
2400 years ago,
the Greek comic playwright,
a really hilarious writer
named Aristophanes,
wrote a play called "The Birds."
A bunch of his plays are gone.
Dozens and dozens of plays
are lost, but seven survive.
And this play called
"The Birds,"
which is the original
buddy comedy.
It would be like Will Ferrell
would be in it now, basically.
These two fools want
to leave Athens
basically because
"there's too many lawyers"
and they build a new city
in the sky.
It might be the first Western
utopian narrative written down.
And that place is called
Cloud Cuckoo Land,
halfway between the realm
of the gods and the heavens,
and the place of the humans
on Earth.
And, that way, they can
intercept messages,
is what they plan.
But, like all utopian
narratives, of course,
it caves in, right?
Like Utopia's never
what they think
it's going to be.
They start eating the birds
that help them
build the city and stuff.
And, of course, they fight
over power with each other.
And that phrase is really echoed
down through our language.
Now, it's sometimes used
in a disparaging way, like,
"Oh, Seth lives
in Cloud Cuckoo land.
He thinks the virus
will be gone tomorrow,"
or something like that.
But it's also kind of
a beautiful thing.
I think it's really important
that we all dream
of better places, you know.
So many human cultures
have told stories
about traveling on long journeys
to better places,
where there is no suffering.
And so, as my kids, you know,
my kids were 10 to 17
while I was finishing this book
and, every time
I'd go downstairs,
there's like another dystopian
thing on TV.
There's another city exploding
or another planet exploding.
So I just thought, "What if I
explored utopian questions?"
Which, of course,
there's a great acreage
between that and dystopian
narratives, too.
What if I explored?
What does it mean
to dream of better places
in this book?
So, Cloud Cuckoo Land,
each of the five characters
kind of dreams of a better place
and works to reach that place,
but, ultimately, maybe, realizes
that home is going to be
the best that it gets
and kind of comes
to an acceptance
that maybe Cloud Cuckoo Land
is this place right now.
This is as good
as it's going to get.
-That would be very nice,
if that
turned out to be the case.
-I hope so.
-I also want to say,
which makes sense to me
because, when I read
"All the Light,"
it's very cinematic,
in a lot of ways,
and it's going to be
a television show,
which is so exciting.
-Yeah, thanks.
It's exciting, yeah.
Netflix is going to make
four episodes
and each is about one hour.
I think I'm allowed to say that.
And Steven Knight,
the writer who wrote
"Peaky Blinders,"
is writing the scripts.
He's really engaged and he's
so good at the crosscutting.
I did a lot of crosscutting
in the novel,
all these short chapters
moving back and forth,
and he's really captured
that essence
in the scripts I've seen before.
And they're going to do a search
for the actor to play Marie.
They're going to look
for a low-vision
or a blind actor to play her,
which is really special,
so I hope they find an amazing
young girl to play Marie.
-It's so exciting.
I really can't thank you enough
for being here.
It's such a delight to meet you.
-Same, Seth. Thanks.
-Thank you so much.
"Cloud Cuckoo Land" is
on sale now
wherever you buy your books,
but please remember
to support local
and independent bookstores.